all right joining us now with more
republican whip steve scalise house
minority leader kevin mccarthy
and the newest leader of the republicans
in the house
gop conference chair elise stefanik
welcome all of you
all right we can spend this interview
talking about liz cheney but i don't
really care about liz cheney
liz cheney decided that she knew better
than the rest of the caucus
but i'll give you kevin mccarthy your
thoughts
on why it was that the entire caucus
pretty much wanted her out
well remember we serve the pleasure of
the conference
and what the conference was looking for
is exactly what you were just talking
about
how are we going to make sure that we
secure the border
stop the socialism save our nation
because
this is not where we were 18 months ago
this is where we were back during the
jimmy carter time
so let's not look back let's look
forward and i'm excited about lee
stefanik coming into this leadership
team
because joe biden is not just ignoring
the problems
he's igniting them this inflation that's
just hit us we have not seen in two
decades
that's a tax increase on every american
and these are the battles that we have
to have listen to you earlier sean
sounds like you've been inside our
conference because that's exactly what
our agenda is
that's what we're taking to the american
public but we're going to fight on the
floor now
to stop this agenda that pelosi and the
show solace are trying to bring forward
yeah and we could probably take out a
betting line how soon it will be that
liz cheney's new friends will be calling
her father a war criminal again
attacking scooter libby again and oh
raising ethical challenges of her father
as it relates to his work with
halliburton because
those are the people that are now
praising her the ones that called her
father a war criminal
side issue all right congresswoman let
me ask you about this position
the acu did have you at a lower
conservative rating than
liz cheney the agenda that i just laid
out which is pretty much the trump
agenda
the make america great again agenda
america first agenda
uh do you disagree with any of the items
that i think republicans ought to be
focusing on
i agree with all of the items sean that
you laid out and most importantly
voters across this country agree we are
experiencing multiple crises under
president biden and speaker pelosi
we have a border crisis we have an
economic crisis and we have a national
security crisis in the middle east
republicans are going to fight on behalf
of american families who are concerned
about the radical direction
this administration is taking us we are
unified as republicans and i am proud to
be a strong conservative republican
that is going to work to unite our
republican conference
and stand up for the american people you
know steve scalise congressman i
i've been watching what's been happening
and i'm very concerned we saw this hack
on on america's energy sector
we now know ransom was paid did joe
biden have a part to play in that i
don't know we see inflation now
uh at its highest number in 12 years 4.2
percent
we have 10 million jobs available
americans getting paid many of them more
money from the government to stay home
how do we how do we get out of this mess
and we've got to help israel and i don't
see health forthcoming from the
administration right sean that's why
it's so important to have a united front
and stand up against this radical agenda
and look joe biden's failure leadership
is on full display but it's hurting
american
families right on day one he cancels the
keystone pipeline killing thousands of
good jobs
he puts a ban on permits and leases on
federal lands
you wonder why in south southeast part
of the country the whole
atlantic seaboard they're waiting in
lines to get gasoline they're paying
five six dollars a gallon for gasoline
uh joe biden by the way
emboldened opec allowed russia to start
bringing oil into the united states we
were producing our own
under president trump because we're
energy dominant and we're able to help
our friends
what's going on in israel right now is a
clear example that this president is
being tested and so far
he has failed to rise to the occasion
you've got to stand with our allies
israel
absolutely has a right to defend
themselves but right now you've got some
leaders on the democrat side in congress
that are criticizing israel openly
that's
he's not standing up to them he's
hurting hard working families right now
killing jobs
inflation is through the roof look at
the lumber prices right now
anything you buy at the grocery store is
up and joe biden is paying people not to
work as you pointed out when there's 10
million people
job openings small businesses that can't
run their businesses properly
are you waiting months right now to get
a refrigerator
or another appliance this is what joe
biden's doing
uh his leadership is absent right now
when we need it
you know you know kevin mccarthy your
hands are tied i would argue a lot more
than say mitch mcconnell
it's a 50-50 split and if the
legislative filibuster if they want to
remove it
they they would need one republican to
make that happen that
because the republicans if they stay
united
they ca they don't have to provide a
quorum for the votes
on the legislative filibuster or packing
the courts
you don't have that freedom but you're
only what five seats away from a
majority
we're only five seats away but that's
true if you're worried about the
filibuster the best thing to do
change the house because if the
republicans can control the house you'll
never worry about the filibuster
hr one and those won't get there what we
were watching right now and i was in the
oval office this week with the president
the vice president the other leaders
i asked him about are we going to pay
for the ransomware i asked him about the
border
he literally said he inherited a worse
problem which is not true
we just arrested a hundred and seventy
did you tell them in april
yes you know what i also talked about
that's what my biggest fear was the
inflation the economy that he's creating
these trillions of dollars from
government when you have a supply
constraint
every economist will tell you what he's
doing is wrong and that he's rewarding
people for staying home
and he tried to move to say i signed an
executive order i said you need to get
out of the white house
go see the small businesses who i talk
to every day and understand the problems
of what's happening yeah let me
ask your observations because i kind of
see joe
as a little bit out of it well a little
bit more than out of it
a little checked out um and i'm
concerned
that i'm not the only one that sees it
as a matter of fact everybody i talk to
says they see it what did you feel
because i saw the picture you were
socially distant you all had your masks
on etc
now i guess you don't have to wear the
mask uh we'll see next time
you know the only reason why they
changed not wearing the mask because
gasoline went to seven dollars and there
was gasoline lines they wanted to change
the news
we could have stopped wearing our masks
long ago i walked out i believe in the
vaccine
i've been vaccinated i don't need to
wear the mask we need to get
back to work back to school back to
health and back to normal
it's simple that's the only thing we
should be focused on what did you
what observations did you did you see as
it relates to the president did he seem
engaged did he have
a high level of energy you've been
around donald trump you've been around
joe biden what
what's the difference between the two
men this is the first time i saw joe
biden as president
since he's been i saw him on the
inaugural um and the state of union
night
he didn't he he was with it and he and
he was engaging and he was giving me
numbers and he was talking
but at no time having known joe biden
for quite some time does he have the
energy
of donald trump we both know it donald
trump didn't need to
sleep five hours a night and he would be
engaged if you called donald trump
he'd get on the phone before staff would
he'd tell bring other people down
in his first week he had a bipartisan
bicameral meeting
inside the white house this was the
first time they had any bipartisan
meeting
and think of the crisis that are
happening they have ignored them
but they're igniting them at the same
time
a congresswoman in this new position
what do you see is the most important
role that you're going to be playing
knowing that you have a few people out
there
adam kinziger etc that didn't want you
in that position
you had a challenge from chip roy how do
you now
i guess maybe alive fears of people that
maybe don't know
where you stand on issues well first of
all i represent a district that voted
for president obama twice and voted
overwhelmingly for president trump
it tells the story of today's republican
party
how we've grown this party among
working-class americans people who work
hard every day
and know that the far left and radical
agenda of the social democrats is taking
us in the wrong direction
the role of the conference chair is to
share our unified conservative message
so focusing on exposing these multiple
crises that american people are
suffering
the border crisis the economic crisis
and the national security crisis in the
middle east
we are focused on reopening our economy
reopening our schools
and fighting for the hard-working
american people that have been left
behind by president joe biden and
speaker pelosi
i think it's telling that president joe
biden spends more time in the white
house than he does across america
when i visit small businesses in my
district and manufacturers
they have jobs available but they can't
hire people to fill those jobs
because the democrats want an incentive
not to work we want to get people
back to work back on their feet back to
school
this is an agenda that works across
america whether you're in new york
texas minnesota louisiana or california
yeah steve scalise a little off topic
but i want to ask you
and i think this is important i noticed
this week that the fbi director
did not declare the shooting in the ball
field where you nearly lost your life
and that is a fact because i you had
told us as much
and other people told me as much won't
say that it's an act of domestic
terrorism
but yet there's all these efforts to
classify
all these hate groups as domestic
terrorists what is your reaction to it
well sean my colleague brad wenstrup had
raised this with the new
fbi director and director ray actually
acknowledged this is something that he
wants to look into
uh mccabe was the acting director when
somehow they came up with a
classification
of suicide by standing his direction
my understanding is he weighed in on
this yeah and i think we we have a
chance of getting this change we're
asking the fbi number one
get the classification right it was not
suicide by cop every other agency called
it domestic terrorism
by the way the two police officers who
were there with me today both heroes
both shot
during the shootout but they were
playing closed officers they weren't
even wearing
police uniforms and he tried to kill
them like he was trying to kill
all of us and so let's get the
classification right but also we've
asked
who was behind this decision and why did
they make that original
classification of suicide by cop which
it's not the ball's in your hands guys
you're the leaders
good luck america needs an opposition
party we wish you we're fighting for
freedom
thank you john hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else